so what did you do did you get an
aggregator to help because you're on all
sorts of platforms from amazon instant
hulu Vimeo on demand xbox all these
things what was your step first step in
getting almost platform yeah I'm
basically what was interesting is um so
we had our world premiere and then I
committed to finishing the DVD which was
sort of like well I guess that's really
finished is if you have a finished DVD
of the foam so I said okay whatever
finish the DVD we released the DVD
actually the day burning man started
2013 and actually went out to the playa
with 200 dvds and i gifted them out to
people on the playa and on that same day
august 26 we release the film online on
our website so you could actually go to
our website and you could download the
film instantly or you could buy a DVD
instantly on our website but i didn't
promote I didn't get the word out at all
I posted one Twitter and I went to
Burning Man my obligation to finish the
film had been met and I had finished the
film and uh but that's not enough you
know it's not enough to finish a film
now you gotta promote now you got to
make sure it's out you got to get the
message out how does anyone know what's
even out well where are these people
where are the film audiences where did
they exist or is it on Amazon is it you
know on Vimeo or how do you find people
that that want to watch documentaries
and so yeah I'm in the middle of a quest
I mean I'm in a quest to find where the
audience is is it in you know on our
Facebook page on our website where they
can download the film via you know
dystrophy or gum road or these amazing
solutions that allow people to just
download straight from the artist or is
it in sort of a bigger arena like Amazon
everyone knows what Amazon is so if
you're there it's sort of like it's
possible for people to interact with
your film it's possible for people to
watch your content because it's in it
it's in something that they know of and
I feel like we're in this strange world
where yes there is amazing solutions
right now with v HX and then me
and real house and justify and and and
India rain you can put your film on
these platforms and they'll take their
ten percent or fifteen percent cut but
then anyone can watch your film and
download it for two dollars or whatever
it is and it's amazing but but you know
it's a challenge of do people know what
those are if I said our films available
on vh x2 to a normal audience member
they'd be like don't know what that is
and I feel like some of these platforms
are making headway there's successful
projects on vimeo VOD they're successful
projects on v HX you know there's
amazing content on real house and they
just sign this amazing deal with Warner
Brothers but you want to get into the
bigger arenas you want to have your film
be available to view on Amazon you want
it you know I'm finding it very
interesting with Hulu we put the film on
hulu also and we don't know our stat we
don't know how many people have watched
the film there yet but you know just
last week we were the hundred and sixth
most popular documentary on there so
that must mean something right there
must be some some numbers that people
are watching it on there and it's all
about trying to find out like how do you
how do you know where people are and
where they're watching content stuff are
you willing to say which one you feels
been the most successful I realize it's
not been that long of a yeah you know
here we are you know two weeks two weeks
out three weeks out from our plot you
know from our internet release on the
online platforms and I feel like we're
still not we're still not really
released yet we have some upcoming
releases you know and then hopefully if
if itunes allows us into their you know
deal them then we'll do that but it's
it's a long waiting list to get into
itunes and other platforms I feel I feel
like Amazon's been good hulu has been
good gum road we do our own digital
download via gum road so someone can go
on our website and actually just
download the full 1080p HD film straight
via gum road and Gummer
nice because they just charge you like a
five percent thing and 25 cents or
something so it's like okay I can make a
deal with whoever and they can take
thirty five or forty percent or I can do
my own version and they'll take you know
their eight percent but then you're on
your own you know then you got to get
the word out about your web site and
have people have people understand that
they can interact directly with you and
I feel like that's still a new concept
it's still you know the audience's know
that they can interact directly with a
filmmaker and I think you know there's
people that are pushing the bounds on
how that works we're a comedian or a
filmmaker will say oh my gosh I finish
this thing it's available now five
dollars and then we've seen you know
these cases where it's just like oh my
gosh you know 50,000 people just don't
you know got my film I think that's
amazing I think that's sort of like the
wish for any filmmakers to have that
kind of success
you